so let's talk about the best way to prepare
your eggs for maximum nutrition and i'm
mainly talking about the carotenoids in the
eggs lutein and zeaxanthin both of these
are very powerful compounds in certain
foods that have very unique health benefits
they're in vegetables egg yolks shrimp lobster
salmon and there's quite a few others it's in
avocados but these two specific compounds
accumulate mostly in the eye they also go
into the liver and certain parts of your brain
but most of it goes into the eye part of the
retina which is the extension of the brain it's
all neurological tissue and the back part the
center part it's called the macula and also in
the lens of the eye so both of these compounds
can help reduce the risk of age-related macular
degeneration as well as cataracts now i would also
recommend avoiding things that cause inflammation
specifically vegetable oils soy corn oil canola
and cottonseed oil those are very inflammatory
and they create a lot of free radical damage
creating destruction to your tissue so the
combination of avoiding the omega-6 fatty acids
and consuming foods high in these two compounds
can help decrease the risk of damage to your
macula as well as your lens now with a cataract
things are going to be cloudy okay like an
opaque type cloudiness on the eye but if there's
degeneration in the macula you're going to lose
vision in the central part as well as
things are going to be less defined
these two compounds also prevent the blue light
they filter out blue light they actually absorb
the blue light and so that's another benefit also
they're anti-inflammatory they're very powerful
antioxidants so now that you understand
the power of these two chemicals and eggs
how do you maximize nutrition how do you prepare
your eggs well they're very sensitive to heat
so the less you heat them the more nutrition
you're going to have so like if you're going
to fry an egg over easy so the yolk is runny
if you're going to boil egg don't overcook it
poached eggs are really good if you're going
to scramble the egg just try not to overcook
it too much now should you consume raw eggs
now the problem with that is when you consume
raw egg whites it can deplete other nutrients
like biotin so i recommend cooking the white part
but leave the yolk runny and of course if
you're new to my channel you want to consume
pasture-raised organic eggs thanks for watching
before you go if you have a question about a
product or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the us hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help